ce cartel d'époque louis 15 il va
bientôt pouvoir sonner à nouveau
mécanisme est arrivé à brouiller il est
arrivé avec des manques dont il ya des
pièces à refabriquer il ya beaucoup de
défauts à corriger dans cet atelier on
soigne les outrages du temps sur des
mécanismes de haute précision datant de
plusieurs siècles comme le rouage de
cette horloge du 19e révolutionnaire
pour l'époque
vous avez aussi un calendrier perpétuel
donc vous allez pouvoir avoir le jour de
la semaine le jour du mois le mois et
les phases de lune est ainsi qu'une
connexion qui se fait mécaniquement
automatiquement toutes les aînés
bissextile
on voyait souvent dans le monde de
l'infiniment petit de la matière de la
métallurgie
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on va que l'on
va voir à la limite de la de l'ue
microscope on est là avec notre groupe
on voit des choses dans ce monde
quasiment invisible après plus d'une
décennie de cette pratique minutieuse
l'artisan d'art vient d'être récompensée
pour la restauration d'un cartel
fabriqué par un horloger d'origine
tourangelle son mécanisme est
extraordinaire car il s'agit d'une
sonnerie à la demande
donc c'est une horloge qui ne va pas
sonner au passage comme on a l'habitude
de rencontrer est elle seulement quand
on tire le petit cordon et elle va
donner
l'indication de l'heure et des quarts
d'heure son savoir-faire leur faivre du
temps là acquis auprès d'un maître
horloger gardien d'une mémoire
inestimable les émotions à chaque fois
on travaille sur des mécanismes qui
remonte à la renaissance et il faut les
entretenir et cetc des mécanismes qui
demande beaucoup de soin et d'attention
pour qu'ils puissent encore fonctionner
dans les siècles à venir d'ici quelques
années le maître passera la main à
l'élève déjà lui-même à l'oeuvre pour
transmettre les arts et métiers de
l'horlogerie française